okay I'm in the lobby of them a lot
look at that secrets and lies floating
in a crowd of data I just reached how to
plucking from the sky and it's mine it's
ours stay focused you got a nasty
security system how much we got we are
the modern-day magicians siphoning bank
accounts out of thin air
no I think someone else is happening in
let's take a peek
stick to the plan Damian and Vince
you're my boy
have faith in your mentor something
drinking that alarm let's find it I'm
shutting down now don't you touch a
thing
what the hell is that we need to abort
Damian
it's over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Maurice yeah you're on one of our
contractors ran his search for the
hackers in the Merlotte job your
assigned Aiden Pearce take him out hit
the family if you need to
this guy's hacking days are done if the
family not a problem
no no see I'm good you'll never hear
from him again
who gave the order don't
if the family not a problem nope don't
forget I'm good
you'll never hear from them again what
do you think boys good job I didn't know
they never gave me a name
I didn't know about any hits all right
that wasn't supposed to happen I want
you to think very carefully think
even if I knew a name you couldn't get
me talking these guys I heard stories
man they're like nothing you ever seen
before you want to walk away from this
man
[Music]
now as you memory now
Maurice won't talk to me then if daddy
talked to you
I need to keep moving
yo Maurice hello it's shaking
[ __ ] where the hell you been
what he's talking to me I leave you for
two minutes
give me my bullets I tossed them but you
said you'd kill him otherwise I told you
to hold on to them joy where you been
anyway I had to make a call and you get
what you need from Maurice oh you're
kidding me it's clean this mess up stop
admiring your work hey that's cute and
all but I'm disappointed Pierce I mean
you failed to spot the nasty inter-gang
drama I'm grading here I don't like
loose ends let's get him out of here no
too late bottom in the eighth
Chicago's ahead games almost over we are
out of time shot huh come on you know
just a little interested in my phone
call all right fine tell me about your
phone call glad you asked
okay we had a bunch of dead bodies right
we got 40,000 people above us we need a
distraction I called the cops you didn't
oh yeah
true story so cops arrived and maurices
little band of brothers arrived
Geordi tell me you're joking no no I
called them to look we got a messy
altercation at the end of the game you
and i slip away undetected they'll
appreciate the plan tomorrow great
punctual cops handle these guys you grab
more ease get him out of here
Maurice what do I look like a chauffeur
is the shooter I'm not through with him
yet
dick
Chicago Police there's anybody in here
identify yourselves
[Music]
I got another corpse another face one
[Music]
the biggest game of the season I pulled
this [ __ ] trying to ruin it brother
spot we've got two bodies in the
basement of May Stadium gangbangers
alright doesn't look right to me why are
they killing each other and why here of
all places
looks like a game
wait I think it's the vigilante does
feel like his brand of justice don't
I wouldn't give to get my hands on that
piece of [ __ ]
Roger the coals now by Jorge Sonova a
winner with an outstanding 15-7 record
last season we're watching an epic
confrontation between two big bass deals
on this team with 27 steals this series
was watching the hawk
see anything nope right here you've got
a known viceroy check them out
okay I'm coming up
so around their speedy meet you down
there make sure we don't get any
surprises
he's not moving unless I give him a
reason
take the bait
are you sir listen are you we're just
talking
look I got my tickets right now no keep
your hands where I can see [ __ ] I
didn't do nothing wrong
get back now your vice fours aren't you
don't get smart
how did you to afford Vipp bet she makes
more than you do hey yo Dee Dee
calm down all right don't get some
nothing use something tells me if we run
you [ __ ] stains through the system will
come up with plenty we can use I need to
see id
Boethius why
fine I don't need ID I'd ask you to
smile but it works better if you don't
hey man I did not give you permission to
take my pictures go Jerome Richards
looks like we got a trafficking warrant
out on youth that we can definitely use
man this is messed up we got right just
keep quiet a minute do have that right
[ __ ] you
[Music]
police are about to lock this whole
place down I'm stuck unless we create a
major distraction I want to cut the
power
and slip past them do it all stay here I
thought you wanted to keep the vigilante
out the news everything's connected you
to see to us with serious firewall right
now I need to get out of the stadium
can you find me the nearest access get
the next room well you'll need to find
someone with security clearance security
guy she'd have access all these cops
he's got to be one around
cowboys and Indians we can close the
Chicago PD
[Music]
[Applause]
why are you Geordi but gone I'm allergic
to cops
those worries but don't worry I left you
a present friend of a friend deals in
pre-owned cars got a real beauty waiting
for you in the garage cross the street
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
goddamn trigger man just need to break
through
push hard I'll give him a couple of days
I've been I'll start reaching out
it took a penis
why are you sitting here
he's coming not like last time Jackson I
did invite him it's been so long
are you sure he called the right number
honey
your uncle's a different kind of person
it doesn't mean he doesn't love us
[Music]
across the road finding Maurice was
correct we gained access to casinos back
door while the police are being
distracted by you since we broke within
this we'll share what we have that back
door allows you some access to the CTOs
Network I've been working on something
bigger give me time